-Hello, everyone,
and welcome back to the attic.
I want to take a quick second
to address something
that was pointed out to me
over the weekend.
According to some
eagle-eyed Internet sleuths,
the title of my trusted copy
of "The Thorn Birds" changed
over the course
of "A Closer Look."
Obviously the last thing
we want is for any book nonsense
to distract from the content
of "A Look."
So to make sure it doesn't
happen this week,
I will be placing a book
on top of my copy
of "The Thorn Birds"
to keep it in place,
and that right there should be
the end of that.
Also I want to note that it has
now been 70 days
since my last haircut, and while
it looks tame enough now,
I assure you that
over the weekend,
this thing is a hot mess.
So thank God for Monday
and a reason to comb it.
Speaking of hot messes,
segue, it's clear.
The president desperately wants
to pretend the coronavirus
will just go away, and now
he's trying to distract
from his own
poor job performance
by calling for his predecessor
to be investigated
for a made-up scandal
he can't even define.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
One of the most frustrating
parts of this pandemic
has been watching countries
around the world from Australia
to Iceland to Taiwan
to New Zealand
successfully suppress
their outbreaks
with competent leadership
and slowly begin to safely
reopen their economies.
Meanwhile, we have a president
who won't even wear a mask
at a mask-distribution facility
while surrounded by people
wearing masks.
Oh, sure, when he was trying to
get everyone excited about coal,
he happily put on
a miner's helmet.
But at a time when experts are
begging people to wear masks,
he stands there like a science
experiment being unveiled
by a bunch of doctors
at a conference.
As you can see, we successfully
implanted the brain of a pigeon
into a giant potato
and then sewed on some limbs
and shocked it with electricity
until it came to life.
So, you know,
still working out some kinks.
Dude, seriously,
just wear a mask.
I promise it won't make you
look less presidential
because there's no way
you could look
less presidential
than you do now.
Do you think we're going to be
bummed out to be deprived
of this part of the face?
Not only have many countries
suppressed their outbreaks,
they've also avoided the
worst-case economic scenarios.
Meanwhile here in the U.S.
we now account for 30%
of the world's cases
despite having less than 5%
of the world's population.
36 million people
are out of work.
We have the highest unemployment
rate since the Great Depression.
And last week the Fed reported
that a staggering
40% of households
making $40,000 or less
lost their jobs in March,
or as the president
put it last week...
-We have met the moment
and we have prevailed.
-Mr. President, you said in
your comments earlier,
"we have met the moment,
we have prevailed."
To you, sir, is the mission
accomplished?
Even with 1.4 million --
-No, we've prevailed on testing
is what I was referring to.
That was with regard to testing.
-[ As Trump ] Sorry,
I read that wrong.
I didn't mean to say
"prevailed."
I meant to say "pre-failed."
We failed before we even knew
what we were failing at.
That's vision.
[ Normal voice ] You can't make
a big statement like
"We've prevailed," then say
it's just on testing.
It's like if George W. Bush's
infamous banner had an asterisk
that said "Mission Accomplished,
specifically the mission
of printing and hanging
this banner."
Also, we have not prevailed
on testing.
I mean, it's good that
we're ramping up testing now,
but we needed it
three months ago.
Bragging about testing now
is like showing up to a house
that already burned down
and offering to water the grass.
Other countries are putting
in place rigorous programs
of testing, contact tracing,
and isolating cases.
That's why they've been able
to slowly reopen
and avoid the worst.
We've fallen behind not just
countries like South Korea,
Australia, and Germany, but
others you might not expect.
-This is what the graph looks
like for the U.S.
You see a sharp rise in cases
that hasn't really tapered off
yet, right?
It's trending down.
But to put that in context,
that curve you see there,
here's how some other places
are doing.
The first group
is the countries that appear
to have successfully suppressed
transmission of the disease.
That curve has
come all the way down
so that they are barely
registering any new cases.
We have Andorra, Australia,
Austria, Bhutan, Cambodia,
China, Croatia, Cuba, Djibouti,
Estonia, Greece, Iceland,
Jamaica, Jordan, Kosovo,
Latvia, Lebanon, Liechtenstein,
Lithuania, Luxembourg, Malta,
Mauritius, Monaco, Montenegro,
New Zealand, Slovakia, Slovenia,
South Korea, Taiwan, Thailand,
Tunisia, and finally, Vietnam.
-We're worse than Liechtenstein,
Slovakia, and Latvia.
I don't even know enough about
those countries to make a joke.
I'll just assume everyone there
is named Gustav
and they chug Fanta
while riding mopeds?
Let us know if we got close.
We even did worse than Bhutan.
Just a side note here
about Bhutan --
What's up with their graph?
Everyone else has a nice
bell curve,
and their chart looks like the
opening credits of "Frasier."
I guess Bhutan figured out that
the cure for coronavirus is...
♪ Tossed salads
and scrambled eggs ♪
No, you're doing a show
in your attic!
Anyway, the point is,
there are lots of countries
that have suppressed
their outbreaks.
And now some of them
are safely reopening
in ways that are still
far off for us.
Like Germany, where professional
soccer returned this weekend,
although with a slight twist.
-Germany could help provide
the playbook
for the future of sports
in the United States.
Today, the Bundesliga will make
a return to the soccer field.
It's the first major sports
league in the world,
along with Korean baseball,
to return during
the coronavirus pandemic.
The move comes as Germany
eases nationwide restrictions
after seeing a drop
in new cases.
-Cheers like these will also
fade away, along with fans,
banned for the rest
of the season.
Still, there will be some fans
in the stands
with supporters paying to have
cardboard cutouts of themselves
sitting in the stadiums.
-That's right, German soccer
fans are paying to have
cardboard cutouts of themselves
in the stands.
It's such a German solution,
because it's so much more
efficient
than actually going to a game
yourself.
[ German accent ]
Sport is merely a diversion
from the ceaseless
march of time.
[ Normal voice ] Angela Merkel
is going to start doing that
for meetings with Trump.
[ As Trump ] You've been
a lot more amenable today.
I like the new Angela.
[ Normal voice ]
Also, true story, side note,
for mother's day,
my brother sent my mom
a cardboard cutout of himself.
Oh, my God,
look how happy she is.
An incredibly thoughtful gift
that made my gift of flowers
with a note pale in comparison.
I don't have a photo to show you
because she didn't take
one of that.
And to my brother,
I would just like to say,
pandemics are not the time
to curry favor with Mom,
to which I'm sure he would say,
even in non-pandemic times,
I get thoughtful gifts,
and you don't,
to which I would say,
"Bud, I would love to have
this conversation,
but I got to get back
to my "Look."
Now, obviously
there are lots of factors,
and those countries are all
very different,
but at least some
of those countries
have made strides in part
due to a national strategy
of widespread testing,
tracing the contacts
of positive cases,
and isolating those cases.
Meanwhile, our president doesn't
even think testing works.
-We've been doing testing
at a level
that nobody's ever done it
before.
We have the best testing
in the world.
Could be the testing is,
frankly, uh, overrated.
Maybe it is overrated.
But whenever they start yelling,
"We want more, we want more,"
you know, they always say,
'cause they don't want
to give you credit.
Don't forget, we have more cases
than anybody in the world.
But why?
Because we do more testing.
When you test, you have a case.
When you test, you find
something is wrong with people.
If we didn't do any testing,
we would have very few cases.
-That doesn't mean the cases
would magically go away.
They would still be there.
You just wouldn't know about
them.
If the Olympics stopped
drug testing people,
there would be fewer positives,
but a lot more cyclists
who looked like Dolph Lundgren,
which might not be terrible.
This is clearly a theme
for Trump.
He would much rather the U.S.
just stopped testing people
so we could pretend
we don't have any cases.
For example, when a West Wing
aide tested positive
for coronavirus earlier
this month,
Trump said it somehow proved
his theory
that testing isn't important.
-She tested, uh, very good
for a long period of time,
and then, all of a sudden,
today she tested positive.
So, uh, she tested positive
out of the blue.
This is why the whole concept of
tests aren't necessarily great.
The tests are perfect.
But something can happen
between a test
where it's good and then
something happens,
and all of a sudden,
she was tested very recently
and tested negative,
and then today, I guess,
for some reason,
she tested positive.
-Oh, he's so close
to getting it.
Sometimes it feels like
we as a nation
are helping the dumbest kid
in school
with his science homework.
[ As Trump ]
She tested negative every time.
[ Normal voice ]
Yes, yes, yes, good, go on.
[ As Trump ]
Then today, she tested positive.
[ Normal voice ] Ah, yes,
yes, yes. Which means...?
[ As Trump ]
Well, something changed.
[ Normal voice ]
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Now, what changed?
[ As Trump ] I don't know.
[ Normal voice ]
She has the virus!
That's what changed.
She has the virus now.
He thinks the problem
with testing
is that you can test negative,
meaning you don't have
coronavirus,
then one day, you test positive
because you caught coronavirus.
[ As Trump ]
Smoke detectors are useless.
They'll be quiet for years,
and then you finally feel
safe enough to leave a candle
on top of a mattress,
and they just start beeping
like crazy.
It's clear that Trump would much
rather simply pretend
coronavirus no longer exists
and go about doing
all the other president stuff
he used to do on Friday,
for example,
as the U.S. death toll
climbed to 88,000,
Trump took time out of his day
to commission a new flag for his
pet project, the space force.
-So today we're here for
a very important --
it's really an important
occasion
because we're unfurling
the flag.
So, why don't we go ahead
and do it?
Let's do it, yes, please.
-Thank you.
[ Camera shutters clicking ]
[ Indistinct conversations ]
-Look at that goon grinning
from ear to ear.
He hasn't been that happy since
Prime had a two-for-one deal
on gold toilets.
I mean, compare that face
to the face he made the night
he found out he was going
to be president.
I would say he looks like
he just saw a ghost,
but it was probably the one
he brought with him.
So amid all of this,
former President Obama
decided to offer some
rare public criticism
during two virtual commencement
addresses over the weekend.
Say what you will about him,
he certainly had his flaws
as president,
but it was so comforting
just to hear a politician
capable of showing empathy
and compassion
and talking in
coherent sentences.
-This pandemic has fully,
finally torn back the curtain
on the idea that so many
of the folks in charge
know what they're doing.
A lot of them aren't even
pretending to be in charge.
And all those adults that
used to think were in charge
and knew what they were doing,
turns out they don't have
all the answers.
A lot of them aren't even asking
the right questions.
Our society and our democracy
only work
when we think not just about
ourselves, but about each other.
Doing what feels good,
what's convenient, what's easy,
that's how little kids think.
Unfortunately a lot
of so-called grown-ups,
including some with fancy titles
and important jobs,
still think that way, which is
why things are so screwed up.
-It's both revealing an
d depressing that when Obama
talks about grown-ups behaving
like little children,
we all know exactly
who he's talking about.
I mean, there's no mystery.
Even Trump knows.
It's not like his aides
went to him and said,
"Sir, he was talking about you,
and Trump said,
[ As Trump ] "Moi? But I was
just sitting here drawing
a new logo for the space force.
Adult stuff.
I think we can all agree,
adult stuff."
Also I appreciate that Obama
did this, I really do,
but as he himself acknowledged,
isn't like one of the upsides,
maybe the only upside of having
your graduation canceled
that you don't have to sit
through a long boring speech?
I mean, don't get me wrong,
Obama is a great speaker,
but instead of giving a speech,
maybe he could have hosted
a game of virtual beer pong.
[ As Obama ] That's two.
Two in a row. I get a rollback.
Hey, there was too much space
between those cups.
I want a re-rack.
Better tighten that [bleep] up.
Tighten it up.
Obama's reemergence comes as
Trump pushes a totally deranged,
made-up scandal
that even he can't define,
but which he's already named
in an attempt to distract
from coronavirus.
And that dumb name has already
been parroted by the media.
-President Trump has escalated
his attacks on his predecessor,
taking to Twitter,
adopting the term "Obamagate,"
hashtagging it.
-President trump calls it
"Obamagate."
-Obamagate.
-Stop trying to make
Obamagate happen.
It's not a thing.
Just because the president
makes up a word
doesn't mean we all have to
take it seriously.
Every day Trump just tweets the
word "Obamagate" in all caps.
There's a good chance it's his
twitter password
and he doesn't realize
he's already logged in.
It doesn't even make sense
as a scandal name.
Obamagate sounds like something
in a sci-fi movie
that we all have to walk through
to restore the correct timeline.
The guy from "Apprentice"
is president,
and the only basketball on TV
is 25-year-old Jordan
highlights!
We have to find the Obamagate!
Trump is so lazy, he can't even
come up with a more specific
scandal name.
It's like the boss who sees you
wearing a hat one day and says,
[ As Trump ]
"What's up, hat guy?"
[ Normal voice ] So the death
toll in the U.S. is over 88,000
and unemployment
is at its highest
since the Great Depression
and the president is accusing
his predecessor
of a made-up crime,
and yet the sociopaths
on the right
like former Bush adviser
Karl Rove, you know,
the guy who looks like you put
glasses on a moldy kumquat,
are more concerned
with Obama's mild, indirect
criticism of Trump.
-It is so unseemly
for a former President
to take the virtual commencement
ceremony for a series
of, uh, historically black
colleges and universities
and turn it into a political
drive-by shooting.
-Okay, I know we've all lost
track of time in quarantine,
but Karl Rove being
a gross [bleep] on Fox News
to get a president re-elected,
is this 2004?
We went back too far!
We gotta go through
the Obamagate again!
The president is just deeply
incapable of
and uninterested
in doing his job.
He clearly wishes
he could just pretend
the coronavirus pandemic
was over,
and to distract from it,
he's peddling a made-up scandal
about his predecessor that
even he can't explain.
That's Trump's one skill --
his ability to exploit
the media's weaknesses.
From birtherism to Obamagate,
whenever he concocts some
deranged new conspiracy theory,
the media responds by saying...
-We want more, we want more.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
During the COVID crisis,
City Harvest has been stepping
up to rescue and deliver
more food to meet the increased
need in New York City.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "Donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
we love you.